hi my name is Alan Shinsky I'm an intern
the Android team and today I'll be
talking about image pixelization I'll
discuss a couple different variations of
how you can achieve an image
pixelization effect using some built-in
operations and using some custom
operations as well furthermore I'll
discuss the use of async task which is
an object in used to offload work off of
the UI thread onto a background thread
and then you can keep your UI completely
responsive while doing some one of the
tricks that you'll see while you're
doing the image pixilation effect is the
fact that one we want to use some
built-in operations where you can
actually do is downscale bitmap an
upscale it back up and you'll see the
use of a flag called filter which we can
use to vary between Bai Ling violating
your filtering and point sampling when
we're actually doing the pixelization
effect so let's jump straight to the
demo right here and we just have an
image of a couple jellyfish and moving
this as we move the sea border from left
to right you can see that the image get
is getting pick size more or less but
you can also tell that as my fingers
moving the zebra gets is behind where my
actual finger is so there's a
significant lack here if we use async
task you can see that the image
pixelization exactly the same as it was
before it takes the same amount of time
but the UI remains completely responsive
and the seekbar never lags behind if you
look here we can also use the built-in
pixelization effect which is
significantly faster and even though
it's still on the UI thread not on
background thread you can tell that it's
so keeping up to my finger exactly where
it needs to be so then jumping straight
to the code and going down there is some
boilerplate code which you can look over
later and you know a simple seaward
listener to make sure that every single
time that the value changes we pick size
the image to get a new pic pixelized
image on the screen scrolling down
farther the more we
we get to where the actual custom
pixelization begins so for custom
pixelization all we're going to do is I
implements algorithm where you're going
to loop through all the pixels in the
image you're going to average the values
of the red green and blue channels
within every single pixel to some value
and then you're going to set that same
pixel value to all the pixels within
that region the key thing to note here
is the fact that when you're retrieving
we're setting pixel values you never
want to use set pixel or get pixel if
you're going to if you know they're
going to use more than those there's a
few methods available in the bitmap
class such as get pixels or set pixels
where you can immediately set in rave
pixels as we get an array of pixels and
it'll be significantly faster so here
we're getting the pixels we're averaging
everything out and at the end we set the
pixels in that bitmap we then return in
a bitmap drawable and then this bitmap
drawable is applied to the image you
which you see on the screen afterwards
now scrolling down further more we move
into the built-in pixelization effect
and like i said before all this does
here is we do a few simple calculations
to determine where the downscaled width
and height should be in order to achieve
that pixelization effect but the
important thing is here when we create a
downscale bitmap we have to set the
filter value to false so what what what
this does is use point sampling instead
of battling your filtering so it doesn't
actually averaged out the values of the
pics of ice around it but it achieves
this very blocky pixel in fact that
we're looking for going down here so
after we downscaled we got when we we
know that we need to downscale it back
up scale it back up so before jellybean
mr1 the way we do this is simply create
a scale bitmap and upscale back to the
original width and height with that
filter value to false however after
jellybean mr one where you can actually
do is create a bitmap drawable and with
that image and set the filter break up
to false the thing is that before jbm
are one we always had the filter bitmap
set to true for some optimization
purposes but what this lets you do here
is not actually upscale the bitmap
simply set the filter and then given
that the image use scale type is fit X Y
when we applied this bit of trouble to
the image you what will happen
upscale it in a much more efficient
matter to fit the whole screen so here
and invoke pixelization this is the
method that gets invoked every single
time the Ziegler's moved and there's two
different things you can do if the
checkbox is checked to use async task
what we're going to do is initialize
this pixel size image async task object
and call execute with the appropriate
parameters which is the the value of the
seekbar and the bit mother will pick
slicing moving in to pick sides
imitating task we can see that there's
two main methods you always want to two
key methods you want to note there's do
in background and there's onpostexecute
so what happens when you call eggs when
you call execute with the appropriate
parameters do in background is called on
the background thread it does the
operations you can see perform here and
when this operation completes on the
background thread it calls on post eggs
you back on the UI thread where we
simply set the drawable to what we want
on the other hand when you if the check
box is not checked then we simply set
the image drawable and this is done
directly on the UI thread which is why
we were seeing the laggy experience
what's crawling the sikh whereas before
so that's pretty much it and that's how
you can do image pixelization and move
things onto background thread when you
need to thanks